les chéris voilà ça y est on les réunit
encore une émission ir très belle
émission bravo à tous alors vous pouvez
pas les voir pour l'instant parce que ce
soit on reçoit mon ami celui dont je
suis très fan pascal obispo qui sera
avec nous dans l'instant je ne vois pas
mon enfant
allons enfants
eager s'est déguisé dans son personnage
dont il est fan
alors regardez on commence par maxime
gainey booth et c'est tintin et lui dit
dans ta vie alors qu'elle est pourquoi
des quines et marianne a grondé pour
vous dire sur les wings alors oui
franchement c'est le plus réussi pour la
côte ont même mis 3 aller promener très
mal exprimé lui magnifique budget
[Musique]
dominateur sur toile et au terminal
bella centre de java
c'est vrai mais ça arrive était très
beau que cette coiffure ah non mais je
te le jure la main
écoute moi à mes toiles à la brosse il a
été alors ça c'est valérie benaïm vous
êtes ans qui dit la vérité toute la
vérité
vous êtes fan de moi ouais c'est un fait
extrêmement plaisir mais c'était merci
mais non merci chérie tu es très belle
comme ça je ressemble à quelqu'un qui
est très beau cfoot alors ça c'est vrai
ou essayer mais vous avez quoi vous iam
expensive elle est chère gothique qui
c'est qui mais oui c'est vieux os à
manger très jeune chef qui vient de
connaisseurs
je
[Applaudissements]
oui
çà et là surprise
il faut empêcher jal à métier que ça ne
va y perdre c'est bien connu
vous avez tous vu à de l'eau de l'eau de
l'eau sa voix souple et moins sur la
gueule
montserrat des mains vertes a mis un
petit peu de manque de dans l'or et
l'intellect mahmoud ould haiba je vais
la jouer live
alors vous êtes en quoi bon joker bien
sûr il ya pascal aussi qui le fait le
évidemment bien ce club lisboète
alors vous vous êtes fan de qui clôt l
ehpad de watala voulu se déguiser en toi
c'est un truc de compte
alors aujourd'hui en plus c'est un grand
jour n'est pas ce que l'on lui c'est
l'anniversaire d'isabelle enfin jeu des
boîtes
non
et c'est ça qu'on gagnera juste
et j'ai une grotte
tu me plait merci
alors maintenant suppôts et vous dit bal
avec cette voiture fait du boulou
ressembler mythique la moustache
jobin
alors sachez que tout le monde s'est
déguisé dans le bas des jaugeurs vous
êtes déguisé en quoi que vous êtes fan
de qui bat en moi réfléchissez pas
trouvé mieux
donc vous êtes déguisant qu'on s'aime
voilà je crois qu'on cartonne en
audience soit les chaînes nous aime je
crois que les fans nous m
je crois qu'on est beau riche et
intelligent la vie est injuste mais
c'est comme ça bah écoute et pôle emploi
[Applaudissements]
ces quotas quant à fait
ça va
[Applaudissements]
mais petite beauté merci d'être là on se
retrouve après le week end
alors je vous dis en plus je tiens le
dire aux téléspectateurs je vais être
très agitées pas ce que je fais lundi
mardi mercredi
je suis en pardonnant voila voila je
raisonnais deux jours ça c'est vous en
parlait dans un instant voilà je vous en
parlais dans un instant mais je d'ici là
je vais faire toutes les conneries que
je peux c'est à dire là maintenant et je
dis je vais redémarrer clim
lundi mardi mercredi ce sera l'ami qui
sera là alors justement mais toi là
voilà parce que j'ai vu un truc ce week
end
je voulais le faire et je voulais le
montrer au téléspectateur il ya un
nouveau jeu fait un carton
c'est que je lance comme ça des balles
de ping pong sur dix comme ça il faut
mettre la tête et met dans le vent le
bail est d'accord accord aussi le temps
mais cinq sur dix alors un peu de chance
aussi
mais il vaut rien ballard sec les
banques fermées bruce cette année sa
curiosité en mai 5 sur 10 je te paye ton
prochain mariage milan et presse n avons
rien vas-y
[Applaudissements]
non
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors oui je suis free oui j'entends de
ma vie
demandez pas qui je suis
tu peux
à
je suis
ouah
je ça
je sais comment ça ma peine on fait de
la merde pas qu'on fait de la mer
c'était toi hanouna je suis de retour ce
matin à les répartit générique on fait
de la merde la mer